Wall Street hopes to rebound today after
big losses brought on by fears of a
recession the Dow Jones Industrial fell
more than 800 points yesterday that's a
big drop closing down more than three
percent it was a worse day for the Dow
so far this year the NASDAQ and the S&P
500 also lost about three percent
earlier the bond market flashed an
ominous warning the yield for ten-year
Treasury notes fell below the two-year
rate and that is seen as a reliable
indicator of a possible recession with
us now is David Rubenstein co-founder
and co-executive chairman of the Carlyle
Group one of the world's largest private
equity firms and manages get this two
hundred and twenty three billion dollars
across three hundred sixty two
investments around the world they have a
good morning thank you how concerned are
you about a recession
well I'm somewhat concerned because we
haven't had one for quite a while you
normally since World War two we've had
recessions every seven years on average
we haven't had one now for ten years you
know so we're due for a recession and I
think there's some signs that we are
gonna head into one but you can't know
for certain until you're actually in it
this warning signal that scared Wall
Street yesterday this so-called inverted
yield curve one of those mysterious
things but it's it's a it's a
significant signal isn't it whenever
we've had an inverted yield curve we've
had a recession every time since 1955 so
it's a good indicator but doesn't mean
it's gonna happen tomorrow the last time
we had inverted yield curve in 2006 it
took about 500 days before we actually
went into recession and I should point
out when you're in a recession or out of
recession the US government doesn't tell
you you're in or out yeah it's decided
by the National Bureau of Economic
Research which is a think-tank in
Cambridge Massachusetts the government
doesn't want to be the business of
saying you're in or out of recession
well you won't really know you're in a
recession till a couple months after
it's actually occurred right so if
you're the average investor sitting at
home right now let's take somebody on
the younger side of things not close to
retirement and also somebody who is
close to retirement what's your advice
to them don't panic
I think people panic because they watch
TV shows and all of a sudden they think
that the world is falling apart the
world's not falling apart
we had a Great Recession a few years ago
and the world survived that came back it
was painful during that time I think
there's a lot of people who wouldn't say
it was a Great Recession for them for
that person who's thinking you know easy
for him to say he's got the reader and
say resilient
is big yeah but today if we have a
recession nobody that I know of is
expecting a recession the type we had in
2007 8 & 9
we're like to have a more modest
recession I'm not saying it's going to
happen well you can never know for
certain I know it's always don't panic
sit tight but David guys in your
position women in your position always
say don't panic everything will be fine
so at what point do you panic I want to
know when you panic so I can panic so
what point should we be panicking when
you reach my age you don't think any
panic about very much when you get up
every morning you're live that's all
that you have to worry about that's a
word but for the rest of the mortals
what point should we be panicking I
think if all of a sudden the global
economy were to go into a recession
where China's growth is negative and
Europe's growth is negative an hour's
negative that's one thing unemployment
would go too high I'm higher than it is
that would be a problem and all of a
sudden if we lost confidence in the
institutions of our country but right
now I don't see that we do have some
problems I think China trade agreement
not having that is a challenge people
are very worried about whether we're
going to go into recession because of
lack of a deal with China I think if we
could get a deal I think it would be
good but it won't be easy to get one I
think the administration is working on
it but the Chinese aren't people you can
just push around so easily they have
their own considerations see the
president that brexit to the president
has pointed the finger at the Federal
Reserve well Jay Powell was is the
chairman of Federal Reserve he used to
work in our firm I have a high degree of
respect for him he worked for us for
about eight years and he's a very smart
person I want to point out though that
Jay pal is the chairman of the Federal
Reserve Board but he doesn't make
decisions by himself there's a FOMC
which actually goes ahead and makes the
decisions about interest rates and that
consists of you know 10 to 12 people and
you think it raises rates too soon
I can't say right now but I would say
it's more likely than not that they will
decrease rates again the market is
anticipating a 50 basis points decrease
in September if that were to happen I
think the markets would be calm down a
bit about that the president has been
very tough on mr. Powell do you think
his attacks are fair I think that Jay
Powell has done a very good job in a
difficult situation it's hard to know
which way the economy is going right now
and remember he's reading the same
economic data as everybody else and it's
not his decision alone the decision
about increasing or decreasing interest
rates is made by the entire
fomc and it's backed by this staff of
the Federal Reserve Board they're very
competent people I think we should have
confidence in the Federal Reserve Board
they've done a very good job I think the
Federal Reserve Board and its staff did
a very good job in the last recession
and I think they're likely if we go into
recession again to do a good job dealing
with the problem but it's too early to
say we're in a recession and your bottom
line is everybody exhale we're gonna be
okay tomorrow it's gonna be okay but you
know you have to be careful and don't
take undue risks yeah all right all
right David Rubenstein we appreciate you
being here when it is time to it's a
panic please come back call us first
yeah